welcome back to Sivir we were so excited
to find out that you were returning for
zombies - Meghan Donnelly
you are so great as Addison in the first
movie we are so pumped to see you and
Milo back in Seabrook you changed the
world through cheer but we got to
wondering are you and your cast mates
really high school students and we know
that we ship Addison and Zed but who are
you two dating in real life we want all
the deets if you can stir the masses
surprised
we love the entire cast of zombies - and
we have their real ages and
relationships lined up for you so don't
go anywhere
you won't believe who Meg Donnelly is
rumored to be dating in real life Milo
Manheim the star of the zombies
franchise is zombie Zed he's a football
playing zombie who was totally in love
with Addison well how would you know
you're perfect
Milo Manheim is 18 years old in real
life he used to date holiday Kregel but
they split in October of 2018 there have
been rumors that he is dating he's
Dancing with the Stars partner alexis
friend the two are definitely close but
neither of them had confirmed a
relationship Emilia McCarthy we know her
best as the Seabrook High cheerleader
lacy she eventually comes around and
decides the zombies aren't that bad this
isn't good
Becky what are you doing lacy is played
by Emilia McCarthy Emilia is definitely
not a high schooler in real life she is
22 years old
Emilia has been acting for a while she
is currently single and focusing on her
career it looks like she is dated in the
past but she keeps her private life
under wraps
Chandler Kinney one of the new cast
members is Chandler Kinney she is
playing a werewolf named Willa Chandler
has been on the Lethal Weapon TV show
you'd be surprised
she also appeared in one episode of Girl
Meets World in real life Chandler is 19
years old if Chandler has dated anyone
she has certainly kept her private life
private
there's no news about any current or
past relationships
Carla Jeffery Addison's BFF bree is
returning for zombies - Bri was an
aspiring cheerleader he became Addison's
friend in the first movie
she is played by Carla Jeffrey she might
look young but Carla is actually 26
years old Wow
we never would have guessed carla has
managed to keep her personal life a
secret so we don't know if she's
involved with anyone right now
Pierce Josa next is another new
character Pierce Joseph plays Wyatt one
of the werewolf's who comes to Seabrook
you might know Pierce as Spider Johnson
from the TV show MEC expore you know
maybe it's friendly I'm sorry I shot at
you he was on the show for two years
Pierce is just 17 years old in real life
that's right he is one of the Seabrook
High students who is currently of high
school age Pierce is currently living
the single life
Trevor Tordjman you know him as Bucky
from the first zombies movie he was the
head cheerleader and he hated zombies we
like to remind some bees that we don't
accept freaks in this town his character
was also Addison's cousin which made
things even more complicated
Trevor Tordjman is back in the second
movie Trevor is on a Canadian TV show
about dancers called the next step for
over 120 episodes in real life Trevor is
23 years old he is currently single
Kingston foster dad's little zombies
sister is doughy we loved her character
and we were so glad she finally got the
dog she always wanted my very own we
can't wait to see her again in zombies -
Kingston is just nine years old she is
certainly getting more and more awesome
roles since she's so young
Kingston definitely is not dating anyone
here so excited to see her grow up and
do awesome things
Kylie Russell Eliza is one of Zed's
awesome zombie best friends and she is
one of the best characters in the movie
yeah we would have cleaned that the
teachers territorial about his mom Eliza
is played by Kylie Russell she has been
a Disney Channel star for a long time
she appeared in the original movie jump
in way back in 2007 she is 23 years old
in real life Kylie has been dating
Samuel hoser since 2016 and they are
seriously couple goals James got free
Zedan Eliza's other BFF is Bonzo and we
just love his character
Bonzo is played by James Godfrey you
might also know him from the Disney
movie the swap zombies was James first
real big role and he did great he's no
teenager like his character James is 22
years old he is currently not dating
anyone
Jasmine Rene Thomas Stacey was one of
the cheerleaders in zombies and she's
back in zombies - Stacey is played by
Jasmine Renee Thomas plain Stacey was
her first major role she's too initiated
reach me she is 25 years old
Stacey is trained as both a dancer and a
gymnast she started lessons when she was
just two years old if Jasmine is
currently dating anyone she is keeping
it on the down-low Arielle Martin the
third werewolf is a winter and she is
played by Arielle Martin you might also
know her as baby Arielle she got her
start as a singer on the musically app
and gained a huge following but how you
get 40 million people following you I
mean I honestly don't
she also played drew on the brat shows
chicken girls and baby doll records
Arielle is just 18 years old in real
life she is dated Blake gray and Zack
Clayton but she is currently single meg
Donnelly Addison is everyone's favorite
cheerleader he just loved her character
this is our revolution it doesn't have
to be cheer though she is played by the
talented Meg Donnelly meg has also been
acting on the show American housewife
for the last three years Megan is 19
years old she's very private about her
personal life but there are rumors she
is dating Logan pepper
she is also real life besties with her
co-star Milo Manheim who is your
favorite character from zombies let us
know in the comment section thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things we'll catch you later
[Music]